As per my recent updated tube swab list,
do you advise me to take Michael Poe 2 caps per day?
Is this zeolite?
So Michael Poe, let me call it up,
is a zeolite product.
It also has charcoal and has cubic and phobic acid.
It has a zeolite.
It has micro-kytesan.
The kitesan is a type of bentonite that particularly stays
in the gut, it is a great binder in the gut.
It has silica from bad blue extracts.
You tell me to continue to take this zeolite that you have,
this is what you have.
Also, I have this already.
The zeolite for detoxy, microtoxys.
Zeolite is not solely for detoxy, microtoxys.
Zeolite is a chelid, so it can chelid and metals.
It can chelid all sorts of different things.
If I'm getting the molds and mills
you eradicated from our house, how long should I take this?
So you take what we could do at other jigsaw
than we could test, whether you still need it.
But we're not trying to.
So understand, I created a blog post,
the different things that mold, different problems
that a person will have with mold exposure.
So with mold exposure, you could have a cute mold exposure
to the phone guy itself, to the mold itself.
So you breathed the mold, you have that exposure to the mold.
That is a pathogen that your immune system will fire
against, to kill that pathogen.
That could make a person sick for a period time, like Aspergillus.
That's going to make a person sick.
They have an acute immune reaction.
They fired immune, TH1 reaction, to kill that pathogen.
It's a pathogen, a living organism.
That is typically only in the acute phase.
You're not going to have long standing typically fungal infection
in your body.
The second issue that you have with mold exposure
is the Michael toxins.
Not the mold itself, it's what the mold produces.
So Aspergillus and other molds produce toxins.
And we can breed in those toxins.
We can be exposed to those toxins through different foods.
Most commonly it's through mold in the home
of moldy building syndrome.
Those toxins are totally different
than the living organism.
So the toxins are just like any other toxin.
It's not a living organism.
It's not a canfire in immune response,
but the immune system will do nothing with a toxin.
Your immune system can't kill mercury.
Your immune system can't kill lead.
Your immune system can't kill Michael toxins.
Why?
Because none of those things are livid.
Michael toxins, like other toxins,
can settle in your tissues and cause damage.
They can damage tissues themselves.
They are in themselves oxidizing agents.
They can damage cell membranes.
If they go inside the cell, they can damage the nucleus.
They can be a cause of cancer.
That's why on a Michael toxin test,
you'll see that different types of Michael toxins
like ochre toxins have been shown to cause cancer
to be cancer-caused agents.
Well, the truth is, anything that gets inside the cell
can disrupt the nucleus of the cell and damage the DNA
and cause it to go a rapid replication, cause it can't.
So three different things that can be an issue with mold,
I said, the living organism.
That's typically only in the acute phase.
Number two is Michael toxins.
These are poisons that will stay in your system.
And definitely, you don't get them out.
So zeolite is pulling out those.
It's not pulling out the mold.
It's pulling out Michael toxins.
Well, if I have acute mold, what would I take?
Well, you're most, I don't usually,
I have to address that with cancer patients
cause you're usually dealing with anything
you're gonna do to stimulate the immune system
is gonna help kill mold.
You're already on immune stimulators.
Well, let's say somebody doesn't have cancer.
They contact me and acute aspergillis is their problem.
Did I use something like phongoclear?
That is something that will help kill those things.
Michael pole is to pull Michael toxins.
Doesn't specifically just do Michael toxins
can help pull other toxins.
No key later is gonna be specific totally
to just Michael toxins.
It's gonna help pull other toxins and heavy metals
and all sorts of poisons out of your body.
The third way that you're affected by mold
is if you're exposed to mold,
you could end up creating antibodies
to mold spores.
These are typically IgE antibodies.
And those are the people that, you know you have that.
You're even a test for that because you know I have it
because those are people that are super sensitive
to any kind of mold.
It, you might know somebody like that
that, oh my gosh, I can't go to that meeting
because when we needed that building at that school meeting,
I just feel, oh my gosh, I can just tell, can't you smell that?
Oh my gosh, I got a headache, I don't feel good.
You know, these people, they're not crazy.
They do have an IgE reaction to mold spores.
Whereas their husband might be going,
what are you nuts?
I don't smell anything.
Don't you smell that mold?
Oh my gosh, I got such a headache.
These people can be listed as a Cypocod reacts
but really they may have IgE antibodies to mold spores
so when they breathe them in,
they're hypersensitive to them
and they have a reaction that's an IgE reaction.
Does the EOLite remove other toxins for the body?
I answered that.